- I don't think there's
anything we can do about it
because he was your boyfriend.
- Shut the eff up you effin' N-word.
- You only have three months to live.
(somber music)
When I went to the doctor and he said
I only had three more months to live.
And it was five months
ago so, I'm waiting.
I have a rare type of tumor,
it's a type of lymphoma.
It's blood tumor, blood cancer.
The life expectancy, it's very low.
- I was at a party and I had
been given a lot of alcohol
and I had ended up in the hospital
and they decided to
perform a rape kit on me
and the police officer
told me, "I don't think
"there's anything we can do about this
"because he was your boyfriend
and juries don't usually
"go for convictions when
it's someone you trust."
Growing up, you look back and
you reflect and you think,
there's things that happen to you
but they make you stronger as person,
so you kinda have to take
it as a learning tool
and just move on and
know that you're stronger
because of it.
- I think I was in fourth
grade, I was on the school bus.
I was talking to my friend
and he was just like,
"Shut the eff up you effin' N word."
- A while back my father and I got into
a pretty intense argument and he told me
that he was ashamed to have me as his son,
and that really hit me
hard and to this day
I still think about that and
use that to kinda motivate me
to be better and try to build
a relationship with him again.
- Why aren't you smart enough?
- [Thoraya] And who said that?
- My mother.
I was working on math homework
and I was probably in fourth grade
and I couldn't figure out a question,
and she straight up asked me that,
and now that I have him
I would never say that
to my kid, ever.
(somber music)
- I was in Mississippi in 1996,
a place called Moss Point,
a little Caucasian boy with his father
called me the N-word inside a McDonald's.
The most painful thing
anyone has ever said to me.
Dad didn't say anything, matter of fact,
it was kinda crazy 'cause I was more mad
at the dad than I was at the little Boy.
- The most painful thing
anyone has ever said to me is,
"It's okay, you're gay but
you have time to change that."
- Bein' away from you
has been so good for me
and my mental health.
- I can't spend time with you Skye,
how bad your mental health is makes you
just a tiring person to be around.
- I don't love you.
- I'm no longer in love with you.
- Let's just be friends.
- I love you but you're not what I want.
- I'm not sure if I'm in love with you.
- It wasn't real.
- No one could ever love
you, you're too broken.
It was kind of a way for
him to make me feel trapped
in the relationship because
if he could convince me
that nobody could ever
love me, I would accept
what he was giving me, which wasn't love.
- It's over.
Yeah, like breakin' up with
me, that's it, it's over.
A few tears fell down and that's it.
I didn't know how to act.
I'ma just leave it at that.
I don't wanna start cryin' out here again.
- You should be grateful that
I'm even giving you attention
because you're fat and no
one will love you anyway.
A guy that I was dating
tried to go too far
on the second date.
- "You were an accident."
My dad act like he was playing,
but that make a mark in my life, so.
- [Thoraya] What's the most painful thing
someone has said to you?
- That I was going to lose my left leg.
- "You're too loud."
Made me feel scared to be myself
and I needed to hide who I am as a person.
- I was in third grade and
there was this girl who,
I think it was the end of the
year, this girl who I liked,
I overheard her talking
with one of her friends
and was like, "Oh, do you like Dan?"
And she like, "Ugh, no he's fat."
And she didn't know I was
there and she didn't know
that I saw it, but it just stayed with me.
I remember just being totally crushed.
- One of my students asked
me why I was even a teacher
because I was failing at my job.
I think that might be it,
one of my own kids just,
yeah, "Why are you even here?"
- I didn't know anyone at my new school,
I was in third grade, and
this boy, his name was Scott,
if you're watching.
He walked by my desk and he tapped my desk
to get my attention and he pointed at me
and he said, "You're stupid."
And that hurt.
I think I cried, and I didn't wanna
go to school for a while.
And the teacher didn't notice
and, I always swore I would.
- Just growing up my dad told me
that I could never do anything
and that I would never
be able to do anything
and I could never leave
the house that I grew up in
and I left, obviously, and
now I'm doing great things
and I'm helping other people
so I proved him wrong.
- Probably something
my dad has said to me,
'cause he said some really
not nice things to me before.
- [Thoraya] Was that your
sister the one before you?
- That's my sister, yeah.
We're actually all
sisters, we're triplets,
so she was saying, "I'm curious to see
"what your answer would
be," 'cause she might've had
a similar answer to me and my other sister
might have a similar answer to us.
Actually no, I think I
might change my answer
because okay, so my mom and I
have always been really close,
but I went through a hard time
when I was in high school,
and she was kind of the person I leaned on
to help me through it, and
at one point she was like,
I was complaining to her about the thing
I was going through, I was
sick, I was in the hospital
so that's why I was complaining.
It wasn't like my boyfriend
broke up with me or whatever.
And she was like, "God, stop complaining,
"I'm so sick of you."
And I didn't expect her to say that,
and it made me so upset and we didn't have
the same relationship
for years after that,
but I think it hurt me the
most 'cause I didn't expect it
to come from her, you know?
So even though, I expect my
dad to say some mean to me,
you know what I mean?
He's just that way so
it doesn't hurt as much,
but when it came from her I
was like, "Mm, that hurt."
So that's probably the worst I would say.
"I'm sick of you."
- I used to have really bad acne
and so I had a lot of scarring
and I remember one day
I went into work without
makeup and my boss told me,
"Oh you look like you do drugs,
"like you've been picking at your face,"
and it was so painful for
me and beyond on that point
that's when I became obsessed with makeup
and for a long time I
couldn't go out of the house
without makeup and even
now I still struggle
going out of the house with makeup,
but I feel slowly I'm
gonna heal from that,
and slowly the words will
just become meaningless,
but they were very impactful to me
and still continue to be impactful to me.
- I was in kindergarten and I was in love
with my kindergarten teacher,
I thought she was just
the coolest thing, but
one of the hall monitors
came in to give her a
message and I saw her
'cause I knew the hall monitor,
and I said, "Hi, so and so!"
And then I heard the
teacher look at her and say,
"Oh, you know that little black thing?"
Changed me forever,
didn't like her anymore.
It hurt my feelings, but it didn't stop me
from loving people.
- So I think the most painful
thing someone has said to me
is that my face is fat because
I have really big cheeks
and I smile a lot.
But yeah, they didn't like
that so they were like
"You're face is fat," so
that was kinda hurtful to me
'cause I felt like that was my trademark,
my cheeks are my trademark, so.
- Somebody called me the B-word
in front of a lot of people
on social media and she didn't
cover the name or anything.
It caused a lot of people
to have a different look on me, so yeah.
- When I was little in third
grade there was these kids,
'cause I used to only hang out with boys,
I played basketball and things like that,
and then this one kid used
to say that I was a boy
and said that I only hangout with boys
because I'm a boy, and it was
just really annoying and yeah.
- I haven't spoken to my
dad in about eight months
so I called him and he
said, he was at work,
he works abroad, and he
said, "I'm at work right now,
"I'm gonna call you later."
And that was about seven months ago
and I never got a call back,
so I'd say in retrospect
that is a hard pill to swallow so,
that would be my answer.
- This kid named Devin, he called me a pig
and told me that he didn't like me.
- [Thoraya] How'd it make you feel?
- It made me feel really
sad, like really sad.
- So my dad had passed away in 2009,
and I was being really mean to this girl,
and I was nine years
old, and then she's like,
"That's why you're dad died."
Because I was being mean to her,
so that's the meanest thing
someone has said to me.
- We don't want you around anymore.
I was 13 and I had really cool neighbors
that I loved very much,
and I couldn't be at home
because at home was hard, and
they were like my home for me,
but then it was just too much for them,
they already had a family
and it was too much
to take on somebody else
who even just hung around,
so that was probably
the most painful thing
I've ever experienced.
But it did teach me a
lot, it teach me a lot
about how makin' home in myself is good.
- My ex husband was a
drug addict, alcoholic,
and he was extremely
emotionally and mentally
and verbally abusive as
well as physically abusive,
and he used to tell me all
the time that I'm stupid,
and that's 100% the most painful thing
anyone can say to me
because I pride myself
on my intellect and my intelligence
and it's the thing that
I think I'm best at,
so he knew that was the
thing that would get me,
so he would say it almost daily,
"You're stupid, you're
stupid, you're stupid."
- The most painful thing that
anyone has ever said to me,
I was 12, I had an accident.
My grandfather was driving a boat,
my leg got hit by the propellor.
My grandmother said, yelled it
when they were bringin' me up
to the back of the
house after the accident
and she said, "Who in
the brought her here?"
Thank you.
- Yeah, thank you as well.
- I think I do feel better.
(somber music)
- Hey guys, thanks for
watching another episode.
If you haven't subscribed
to my channel yet
and you want to subscribe to my channel,
please make sure to hit
the subscribe button
and the little bell next to
it so you'll get notified
every time I put up a new episode.
And if you really, really like my episodes
and you have some friends that you think
might also like them,
so it would mean a lot
if you shared my episodes
with them as well.
If you want.
I think that's pretty much it.
Thank you guys again and
I'll see you next week.
(somber music)